[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
from the fashion to the PDA they look
like a couple very much in love and to
baby Archie sightings
Prince Harry Megan Markel and Archie's
tend a royal tour of Africa was packed
with amazing moments after a summer of
negative headlines the Royals seemed to
have landed themselves back in
everyone's good graces and flying
commercial didn't hurt I think we're
going to see an emphasis on the Duchess
playing down the glamor stakes after
touching down in Cape Town last Monday
the sixes were greeted by music dancing
and adorable children but our favorite
moment came on day three when they
finally gave us what we've been waiting
for all along baby Archie the five month
old was quite the charmer meeting
retired Archbishop Desmond Tutu and his
daughter and in addition to seeing our
favorite Royals putting their parenting
skills on display the tour also
highlighted the fact that the Duke and
Duchess are still very much in love
Harry will put his hand on the small of
Megan's back they were holding hands he
and Megan shared a kiss there's a lovely
energy between them after spending three
days in Cape Town the Sussex is parted
ways Harry jetting off to three remote
African countries making stop number one
in Botswana yes I came here when I was
97 98 Austria when one died so it was a
nice place to get away from it all but
now I feel deeply connected to this
place and Africa
the 35 year old royal went on to pay
homage to Princess Diana in Angola he
literally followed in his mother's
footsteps through a minefield in Angola
I'm incredibly proud of what she's what
she's been able to do and meet these
kids here who were born on this street
right she didn't even know that this was
a minefield then he was off to Malawi
where Megan Skyped in during his visit
with members of the campaign for female
education meanwhile the new mom was busy
advocating for women in South Africa
because everything is based on heard
she's few time so it's a full plate for
them we're making it work it's worth it
Megan met with female entrepreneurs at
ladies who launched as well as a group
called mothers two mothers that trains
and employs women living with HIV where
she donated some of our cheese toys and
clothes
on her final day before reuniting with
Harry for reuniting - that wasn't so
much the Duchess highlighted the
importance of education for women at the
University of Johannesburg then this
bombshell dropped this announcement that
the couple of taking action against mail
on sunday has come as a complete
surprise
this after the British tabloid published
a private handwritten letter Megan sent
to her estranged father here he followed
up the announcement with a statement of
his own attacking the press for
vilifying his wife and comparing it to
their treatment of his late mother
adding that his deepest fear is history
repeating itself why after eight days of
glowing headlines brilliant positive
press coverage they've chosen to end the
tour on what is essentially a very sour
note by issuing an unprecedented press
statement but it was all smiles when
Megan and Harry finally reunited in
Johannesburg on day 10 ending their time
in Africa meeting with Nelson Mandela's
widow and these lasting remarks will
make sure that what I've learned here
the value of the natural world the value
of community and friendship is something
that I can pass on to him
you